The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
Hi I'm Sal.
Today we're going to be doing
problem number 5 of
fall 2009, test 1.
Make sure that you read the
problem in full detail before
attempting the problem.
And there's also some things
that you should know, pretty
much background material.
Before attempting the problem.
And that's what I need,
which is W I N.
You will win if you know how to
manipulate these equations.
The first equation is the energy
of two charged species
as a function of their
internuclear separation.
And the other equation is
a function of just the
separation between two ion pairs
at equilibrium, which is
given by r naught.
And r naught is just simply the
sum of the radii of the
cation and the radii
of the anion.
So if you look at this
equation there's two
components to it.
The first component is actually
the component that is
responsible for the attraction
of your charged species.
And the second component
is the repulsion of it.
Because essentially ionic
bonding happens because of
your electrostatic interaction
between an
cation and an anion.
So with this in mind we can
go ahead and read the
problem and solve it.
So the problem reads
as follows.
On the same graph below--
and this is the actual graph
that we're going to be doing
the problem on--
it says on the same graph
below, for one, BeF2, so
beryllium fluoride, and two,
BeO, which is beryllium oxide,
sketch the variation of
potential energy with
internuclear separation arc
between a cation and an anion
pair in each compound.
The diagram need not to be drawn
to scale however you
must convey the relative
magnitudes of key features.
So the first thing that I would
do is write down my
compounds that I'm using.
So I'm focusing on beryllium
fluoride, is the first one.
So if I look at beryllium
fluoride, I'm going to look at
the relative magnitudes and
charges when they're in their
cation and anion state.
So I know that for beryllium,
beryllium forms a
cation that is 2 plus.
So it has a positive charge of
2, which means that it lost
two electrons.
So I can say that z plus for
beryllium is plus 2 and for
fluorine, when it's in the
anion state, my charge is
equal to minus 1.
So 2 plus minus 1.
So with this in mind, you can
take this and it will help you
solve the problem.
Because like I said, the first
part of the equation is pretty
much the attraction part, which
involves the product of
your charges.
And I want to go ahead into
the same thing for--
so this is for BeF2.
And for BeO we have the
oxygen 2 minus.
So my anion has a z minus of
minus 2 and my cation just has
z plus of plus 2.
Now if you look at your
equation over here.
There's two things that will
dominate at certain
parameters.
Now this value of n is known as
the Born Exponent, and that
has a value between 6 and 12.
So it's always greater than 1.
And this is actually what's
nominating your repulsion, so
I'll do some colored chalk.
So for the attraction
part I'll circle it.
And the fact that it's being
attractive means that one of
these charges has to be negative
that will make the
overall component negative.
Right here because you'll
have q1 times q2.
And in our case if we look up
beryllium fluoride, you have
beryllium 2 plus you have
fluorine minus, so if you make
the product of those two
you get minus 2.
And you have this other
component, that is the
repulsive part.
So if I was to draw these
independently, not as a sum, I
know that for my attractive
part, which is the negative,
it should look something like
so, as a function of r.
And my repulsive should look
something like so.
And this makes sense because as
your radius becomes smaller
and smaller then essentially
if you get below 1, your
potential energy curve
for your--
the component for
your repulsion--
spikes up.
So if I was to superimpose
these two, then I should
expect that the curve to
look something like so.
Now this is good because this
is exactly how the curve
should look.
And there's some characteristic
features here
that we want to go ahead and
use BeF2 BeO2, draw on the
same diagram to compare
together.
And this point right here on
your r-axis is simply just
your r naught.
So it's just the sum of
your cation radius
and your anion radius.
And this valley here is your
energy at r naught.
Which is the second
equation that you
should know how to apply.
So if I want to analyze my
system, how do I know which
one has a bigger radii
than the other?
Well I know that my
cation is common.
So in both cases I'm dealing
with beryllium cations.
But I'm dealing with
a different anion.
Now I know that both fluorine
and oxygen anions have the
same number of electrons, from
looking at the Periodic Table
of Elements, or their charges
that they have. But fluorine
has one more proton.
So what that does is that it
allows the fluorine to pull
the electron cloud tighter
together and that decreases
your radius.
So just by looking at the
Periodic Table of Elements, I
can already assume that my
radius for my fluorine should
be less than the radius
of my O2 minus anion.
So if I look at my system than
I know that if I want to look
at the internuclear separation,
the r naughts of
the two compounds, then
I should assume--
or have an educated
guess based on my
data that I have here--
that r naught for beryllium
fluoride should be less than
the r naught for beryllium
oxide.
So this allows you to put the
position of your radius on
your curve.
So I'm going to go ahead and
just redraw the a new axis
over here just to compare
both of them so you
won't confuse yourself.
So we know this is the
energy of our system.
And we concluded that our,
that the radius of your
beryllium fluoride is
less than the radius
of beryllium oxide.
So I can go ahead and mark this
as r naught of BeF2 and
I'll mark that as
r naught of BeO.
So this tells me exactly where
the low point of my potential
curve should lie.
But how do I know how deep
it sits in the well?
Well that's going to be dictated
by the equation that
governs the energy
at r naught.
And that's our simple equation
of when it's the
function of r naught.
And if you look at the equation,
the equation is just
the product of your
two charges.
So if we come back and we look
at our analysis here, we know
that if I multiply these two
charges together, you know the
combination of these two,
should be, q1 or q--
beryllium 2 plus, I'll
call that q1 and I'll
call this one q2.
The product of these two
gives you minus 2.
But for this one, q1 q2
gives us minus 4.
So this tells me that the
electrostatic interaction for
beryllium oxide is
a lot stronger
than beryllium fluoride.
And it makes sense because you
have plus 2 and minus 2 being
attracted to each other instead
of plus 2, minus 1.
So on my graph I can assume, I
can guess, that my value of my
beryllium oxide should sit
lower, more negative, on the
potential curve than
beryllium fluoride.
So if I designate this as the
low point for my beryllium
fluoride then my curve for
this system, for that
particular compound should take
a certain type of shape.
And so again, this is
your energy, the
bottom point of r naught.
And if this is the energy given
to the fact that we have
a higher magnitude when you
multiply the two charges
together, then it should sit
lower on the potential well.
And this will be my low point.
So my curve should also look
something like so.
So if you were able to do this
on the exam you would have
gotten full points,
which is good.
And, again the key points about
this problem is just
knowing what equations to use
by reading the problem.
The problem talked about
internuclear separation, well
we've learned in class how to
treat those problems and how
to use equations to be able to
describe the way that the
energy should look, which
is a good visual.
And by looking at the Periodic
Table of Elements, just
thinking about how many protons,
how many electrons
certain cations have, you should
have an estimated guess
of what your ionic
radius should be.
And with that you can go ahead
and look at the math.
Look where that parameter plays
a role in your equation.
And then decide whether or not
it'll be greater or less or
what have you.
So with that in mind, I dare you
to try the problem now and
give it a good shot.